"She-Hulk" smashed it with all
those cool cameos in Season 1,
but the final guest spot might just
be the most exciting. Here's why.
Season 1 of "She-Hulk: Attorney at
Law" featured several appearances
from characters across the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, from The Hulk to Wong to Daredevil.
"I just wanna make sure that you don't think this
is one of those 'cameo every week' type of shows."
That hasn't been something that fans
have been complaining about, though,
as many tuned in to "She-Hulk" specifically to
see Daredevil in action, since his appearance
was teased in an early trailer for the show.
Entire threads on the Marvel Studios subreddit
were dedicated to discussing when "The
Man Without Fear" would finally show up.
In a Marvel.com interview with the show's
creator, Jessica Gao, she talked about how
thrilled she was to be allowed to use
a character like Daredevil. After all,
Matt Murdock is no stranger to the courtroom
or the superhero lifestyle. Gao explained,
"It just made so much sense that he would be on
this show because both he and Jen are lawyers by
day, Super Heroes outside of the office,
even though Jen is doing it reluctantly.
What better character to kind of show how
this struggle she's having is possible?"
But, while Daredevil may have been
the focus of many fans' attention,
the character casually introduced
at the end of the "She-Hulk:
Attorney at Law" Season 1 finale
might be an even bigger deal.
At the end of the finale, Jen Walters, her family,
and Matt Murdock relish in the defeat of the
conniving Intelligencia group. Unexpectedly,
Bruce Banner — who spent much of the series
in space for unknown reasons — shows up at the
family barbecue to introduce his son, Skaar. He
appears only briefly and doesn't have any lines,
but it still opens the door for this character
to enter the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
In the comics, Skaar was canonically introduced
in "World War Hulk" #5 as part of the plotline
where Hulk was banished to the planet of
Sakaar. Hulk conceived Skaar with Caiera
the Oldstrong and the child matured very
quickly, becoming a teen in just one year.
In addition to having his father's powers,
Skaar also has his mother's abilities known
as "Old Powers" which include being able
to control and manipulate the earth itself.
It's notable that Hulk has already
spent time on Sakaar in the MCU,
after Thor found him there where he had
been spending years in Hulk form fighting
in tournaments held by the Grandmaster.
Not much is explained in the brief scene
introducing Skaar, but Bruce says he
made a return trip to the trash planet.
"I know I've been away on Sakaar for awhile."
Fans on Reddit were already excited
about the opportunities that Skaar's
introduction makes possible. One posted,
"I just hope we'll know more about what happened
to Bruce on Sakaar in another serie[s]/movie."
Others shared concerns about the
character's design, with one fan posting,
"Can I just say that Skaar looks...
off. Not referring to CGI, just,
doesn't look like Skaar and looks like a
Hulked up space teen and not the warrior."
If Marvel decides to redesign the
character for future appearances,
it would hardly be the first time that happened.
But, misgivings aside, it's likely that
Skaar will appear again in the near future.